in the world of fashion it takes
more than just a great sense of
style to build a successful business today
we're taking you behind the scenes with
four incredible entrepreneurs who build
thriving apparel Empires each generating
over a million dollars in Revenue discover
their secret to success and the challenges
they still face in this ever-changing
industry let's meet our fashion moguls
hi my name is Paul long I am the founder and
president of anian clothing we're based out of
the West Coast of British Columbia up in Canada
and we specialize in post-consumer waste textiles
so we take all of your old clothing natural
fiber based we shred it all up into a mulch
and then re-spin it into usable Yarns so we
don't dye any of our clothing and then we use
those Yarns to then weave into cloth and then we
use that cloth for our clothing so we specialize
in wolves as we are up in the Pacific Northwest I
started in 2013 formalized it in 2016. have been
doing this for about 10 years we have a team of
ranging from 18 to 25 people we have two stores
a warehouse a wholesale division all that sort
of stuff and I got my start doing design work
for remote Wilderness lodges so all of our goods
are made in Canada and uh if you go to the middle
of nowhere in the Pacific Northwest you will
see us everywhere hey I'm Dana donipray and
I'm the founder and CEO of Anna Ono which is chest
inclusive lingerie so we say two boobs one boob no
boobs or new boobs we are here to support you and
we are redefining the lingerie Market to include
all different chest types no matter what breasts
are there or aren't there we've been in business
now for a little over nine years I started after I
received a breast cancer diagnosis in my early 20s
mid-20s and I've been a fashion designer for over
20 years so to me this was everything that I know
how to do we're located in Philadelphia we sell
our bras around the globe we're mostly a direct
to Consumer business online with some wholesalers
such as Soma third love Nordstroms Neiman Marcus
Etc this is like my passion it's everything
I love to do I love building product owning
my own fashion brand was always a dream of mine
but happy to have this conversation because a
million dollars uh run Ray sounds great uh until
you start doing it there's more to it so excited
to share more I'm the older brother some say
smarter brother so I guess I'll start I'm Brad
Manning I'm here with Brian Manning my younger
brother together we are two Blind Brothers the
name comes from the fact that we both have a rare
eye condition called star guards disease where
you lose Center Vision over time we were diagnosed
as young kids seven years ago now we were walking
around talking about some of the medical progress
through the foundation fighting blindness which is
the organization that funds all the pre-clinical
research for eye disease we were shopping in a
store we lost each other I lose Brian everywhere
I go but I can usually hear his super loud voice
and see his visually impaired friendly head and
so we lost each other in this store we come out
coincidentally later with the exact same shirt
what we realized is that we you know if you can't
see the prices the colors the labels whether or
not it's a men's shirt sometimes you touch it and
you figure out if you like the way it feels
and we've always had that vigilance to touch
whether it was Fabrics or learning to read Braille
growing up and so when we walked out of that store
we had this aha moment what if this was our way
of contributing back and making tangible some of
what is usually tough to make tangible with this
medical research so we thought what if we create
the softest clothing that we possibly could and
donate all of the profits back to the foundation
fighting blindness to help find that next cure
for retinal eye disease and that's when we came
up with our brand for two Blind Brothers and I
think I took all the good stuff so I don't know
if Brian if you have anything else to add you did
great I'm really proud of you for the front half
uh and you know and I'm Brian Manning and we are
almost entirely direct to Consumer built on the
backs of you know Shopify and the other that Brad
didn't talk about is the community that's come up
around this has been really the extraordinary part
of making sure that we're telling our authentic
story directly to the people that want to hear it
the most and being cheerleaders and evangelists
for the Blind and Visually Impaired what would
the advice be if somebody's just getting started
wants to make it big in the apparel business
what would you tell them that they must do the
one thing that I hear and know even between the
three of us is we've all been able to essentially
elevator pitch why we are different so whether it
is full breast inclusivity through the different
bras whether it is clothing that immediately uh
can provide a positive impact for eye research or
anion that focuses on post-consumer waste all
of us within less than 30 seconds even in the
first sentence have been able to identify
what we are and what makes us different
in a world that you can buy a t-shirt at
a dozen places on every single block in
every single city across the world
how are you going to be different
and it seems that that's a question that all three
of us here have asked ourselves and really driven
down to and being able to straight up why are you
different and what do you do there's no humming
there's no hawing there's no maybe we're this
maybe we're that all three of us know exactly
what we're doing and we stay within our lanes
I think to add on to that Paul great is by as
a clothing business are you a consumer product
business or are you a fashion business because
they are two very different things and they have
two very different routes and spending over you
know 20 years in the fashion industry myself
you know I I really try to encourage people
that if you're going to be a fashion brand
right you have to be fashion and you have to
think of fashion channels you have to sell your
story to the consumer because they want to live
your lifestyle uh whatever that is but if you're
going to be a consumer product and maybe more of a
marketing channel maybe more of a a product with
a hook right whether that's you know funding uh
research for the blind or you know recycling wood
pulp or like we do with chess inclusive Intimates
you know you're also you're playing in two
different worlds really you're playing in clothing
but you're also playing in consumer product goods
and those worlds do function quite differently so
like knowing your lane and what your goal is is
a huge part of navigating the whole landscape of
what does clothing mean to you I think to do that
is you don't have to be Cortez and burn the ships
behind you you don't have to mortgage your house
you know raise money from your family go halfway
bankrupt hope you land on free parking to get the
cash you can go out and start incredibly small I
mean building a website is is very inexpensive and
very and pretty and easy these days running some
original kind of social ad with just you talking
to a camera about why your product's great doing a
small run to really find out who that hyper Niche
audience that is going to Care the most about what
you're doing I mean when we were getting going the
Blind and Visually Impaired Community making sure
to donate to research sounds like it's about this
big until you start to get into it and then you
realize there's 11 million people that suffer from
retinal eye disease that's a lot of cousins and
brothers and sisters I'm sure the number of folks
that have that need chesting or breast inclusive
bras is enormous I just wouldn't think about the
size of it originally so it's not trying to take
over every t-shirt in the world it's what's that
tiny percent of population that's going to care
about what you say more than anything else in
the world and then just start small with them
and then let yourself kind of grow and grow
and grow yep I would totally agree with that
um you know one thing I think that we all can
appreciate is the access to Consumers today
20 years ago it was very difficult to have the
same access to the amount of consumers that we
do today it is an entirely different playing field
today than it was five years ago and it changed it
up even more more people are used to purchasing
online through it some people did over leveraged
through that direct to Consumer and we are seeing
some of that pushback now that being said you're
seeing all generations purchased digitally now um
it sounds like all three of us here are on Shopify
which is a great uh platform for us to get that
direct consumer and you're right um Brian it isn't
as difficult today as it was 20 years ago to get
into this industry because you're not paying the
triple net downtown you're not getting that walk
by traffic but what you do need to do is you do
need to focus on what is that new generation how
is that new Digital model working and just you
know you mentioned it as well just keeping your
overhead as low as possible Evan you mentioned
everybody wants a fashion brand and you know a
Million Dollar Plus and they think it's all glitzy
um you know and Diana you mentioned it's like well
you do that and then you realize that that's not
actually that much you know because there's so
much movement of goods and product and this and
that so I would recommend like try to keep your
overhead as low as possible and don't worry about
people's perceptions you know like I was using I'm
in my office my home office as it's now officially
called uh it is a Murphy bed here and I did
fulfillments out of here for years there's there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with using your ants and your uncle's garages
which I did for years as warehousing none of that
is bad that's part of your story that's part of
the uh creativity to solve these sort of problems
that will get you to that million dollar and and
larger so you know like it is uh it is easier now
than ever before to access these consumers as we
all have mentioned that we are direct consumer
and it's also so important for you to keep that
low overhead well you are learning about your um
your core people and then how to expand that core
customer as you grow and as your facility is in
your processes and all that sort of stuff grows
as well talk to me about marketing I mean you've
probably tried a million different things most of
them did not work what are the ones that actually
did move the needle that if you are starting over
again you'd be like this is where I would spend
my time energy and limited dollars the internet
you know this was touched on a little bit um
uh earlier but I I think that point because
if we're talking about apparel Brands this
is going to be the case for 90 of Brands
as it was mentioned earlier you know are you
actually like a consumer product that has a
feature or are you a fashion brand and and for
most people getting into the apparel base they
you know it's a hard place to innovate from a
cons from a consumer feature perspective and
so most of the folks out there that I think are
are looking at this are thinking that there's
going to be a sort of a fashionable lifestyle
element to it I think one thing that people
don't appreciate is the bar to get attention
on what you're doing it's higher than you think
um meaning that the story that you tell the story
that you tell the way you tell it is going to have
to be the most interesting thing that someone
has heard all that week I've done a good job
of telling our story but I'll also say that the
story gets better and better and better the more
you live with it you may have an initial kind of
spark and feeling and way of communicating it but
it's over that sort of bumping it up against that
wall against others where you'll get better at at
saying and they'll be the in and you'll find the
nuances of it that really connect with people
when it comes to advertising I mean in marketing
it's a very very quick evolving landscape that's
the one thing to keep in mind is that you know
it's a lot of testing that's the cool part is
you get immediate feedback whether you're you know
you're running social ads or you're running Google
ads you're I mean all of it could theoretically
work at different levels of scale what I've been
shocked by is every every six months there are
major changes in these platforms some of which
we built our entire business on initially and then
became you know my a minority of our media spend
um so that that from a marketing perspective
um trying new things uh not being too overly
concerned I mean at least with a lot
of the brands that we follow it's gonna
be too overly consumed with the production
value of the marketing that you're doing and
um and think about Channel message fit like are
are there certain channels that will fit because
your customers there or just the format is better
early on we did long form video on Facebook and
Instagram which was actually they tried to deter
you from doing but we had a long story to tell um
that's not the case now because things change but
um but you know finding that channel marketing fit
is very important to piggyback on that Bradford
is I think too like you know there's an age-old
saying meet your cuss customers where they are and
you really have to understand your demographics
you have to understand who is your ideal shopper
because you know a lot of what we do we dress a
lot of a breast cancer community so sure I was 27
years old when I created my line but most of my
customers are over the age of 55 or 60. so before
it they weren't even shopping for bras on the
internet it was very difficult for me to get to my
core key consumer because she was too difficult to
find covet helped us with that a little bit they
brought an older generation into the internet
environment that felt comfortable shopping but
you do have to identify where is your consumer
and how are you going to get to them because I can
listen to tick tock ad rules all day long but if
my consumer is not on Tick Tock I can't advertise
there that is a waste of my money and is a waste
of my time it is a waste of my energy so like you
know contrary to popular belief like Facebook is
one of our strongest channels because that's where
my demographic is right so you know you can look
at the trends you can look at where the market
is but if you don't really know your consumer
and who's shopping you like you can fail very fast
right and it's hard to it's good to fail fast but
it's also hard when you're constantly failing fast
because you're maybe not paying attention to those
like consumer details um we're like a hybrid
world or in-person events or you know working
with a medical community might be your pathway to
your end consumer but it might feel more offline
than online and there's you know and always a
striking a balance between those worlds is super
important yeah I'd also say you don't know what
part of your story connects with your customer
so make sure that the story that you're telling
is the same story that you're telling you know and
if we're in it every single day you get tired of
that story because you're seeing it every single
day to every single person and you're convinced
everybody in the world knows your story and then
you meet some person in the same city as you
I live in a city of 80 000 people and they're
like wait what do you do I've had a store here
for 10 years but you can't be dissuaded from
that and you need to continue to tell your story
the same as you tell it to every single customer
because you're not sure what part of that
story connects with that exact customer
um and I think that that is very very
important you know because we don't
know which part that they connect
with and another thing that I would
um note on Annie and makes a wide variety of goods
so we're we make jerseys we make knits we make
wovens we do menswear we do women's wear we are
a little bit fashion but we are a little bit more
outdoorsy so we sort of straddle that I designed
clothing that I may not like my customers like
it so maybe I want to dress in bright colors and
floral prints or based in the Pacific Northwest
that is not what our customer base wants so I
learned very early on and very painfully that I'm
not going to have a successful business making you
know flamingo pink tank tops I want that that does
not mean I'll buy as many as you can make buddy
you just ship them down to Virginia hi yo you got
you got a customer in me exactly and I think that
that is something that a lot of people can lose
along the way is as all of us are designing and
Manufacturing and creating our products we need
to have an understanding of what that customer
is meet them where they're at but also ensure
that that the products that we are creating are
what they actually want and not what the designer
or you know the owner may think that they want so
diving a little deeper into that how does somebody
determine the right product Market fit I mean
your your first design was probably not the one
that you're selling right now and it's easy to get
lost and spending tons of money on the wrong path
so how do you quickly test a product get it to
Market start making revenue and not buying 10 000
of something and it sits in your mom's garage test
test like as as Slim as you can be to get there
first is your best even if you're even if your
margin suffers right and and this is like contrary
to a lot of popular belief but like if you can
make a hundred instead of making a thousand
um but maybe you're paying double the amount
right like you can curb a lot of your risk
by testing first and rather than going in and
jumping right into an Asia manufacturer buying 10
000 pieces and then realizing that they break it
or miscommunicate it anyways right so it's like
it's one of those things where you do have to
kind of really give yourself an opportunity to
make sure that the product that you're making
is viable right and that somebody wants to buy
it and Shop it because I do want to say like I I
find that that's like the biggest uh being in this
industry for 20 years that's usually where people
fail because it does cost money to make product
you don't get to get that for free unfortunately
so money's going out the door if you can't recoup
it because all of those goods are damaged or they
didn't fit or they were ill-fitting then you're
you're kind of dead in the water before you even
got an opportunity to start yeah and just just
to add to that somebody's testing your clothing
it's either going to be you or it's going to be
your customer so decide who's going to be doing
the testing and who's going to be wearing it
because if you don't test it they will and the
reputation towards your brand and your company
and your future is going to be more detrimental
if you have to recall x amount of units because
you put them out there and you didn't do your due
diligence so you know Diana like you were saying
it hurts because you're spending so much time and
so much upfront money and when I started Annie and
um I didn't have my six months planned out I
didn't have my 12 months planned out I didn't
have my two or three years planned out I
was just swinging from the hip and hoping
um and I did make a lot of mistakes along
the way and it's taken a long time to build
up that multi-year plan so one thing that I
would recommend is before you you know launch
um have some good have some good designs have
some good Supply systems have some good future
uh products and ideas that you sort of have
sitting on the shelf just waiting to pull the
trigger on whether they are your T-shirt design
means your production any of that sort of stuff
because by the time it comes for you to to make
that decision you need to have already done all
of the uh pre-work to make sure that that product
is solid to Launch yeah you know the other thing
about I think it's interesting um you know this is
certainly true for Brian Eisner it sounds like it
might be true um for the others as well but what's
interesting about the product Market fit question
is that you almost have to be a little delusional
to think that the world needs another clothing
item that only you can make that only you can make
you know the fact of the matter is Brian and I
got into this because we cared tremendously about
doing this together we didn't have a business plan
we thought we would do this for the foundation
fighting blindness we sell a couple hundred units
at some fundraising events for ffb and then we
got some you know we got some media and and it
started to grow from there we were doing this
regardless of the business opportunity and we
had a radical passion for this and so what's funny
is anybody putting together a business plan for a
clothing brand and it's going to face a lot of
scrutiny from anyone who they're raising money
from who's coming in alongside them Etc it really
has to start with a deep question from the person
starting it uh so it has to be something that you
enjoy so much I mean even Steve Jobs has made this
point I think where it's like you almost have to
be crazy obsessive about it because it it can be
so tough and so you know the chance of failure so
high that you'd almost you'd almost do it anyway
what do you guys struggling with right now so if
you look at give people a a peek into the future
struggles that they're going to face as they
continue to build their business you've crossed
a million dollar threshold what's the biggest
thing that you're wrestling with right now we've
sold out however many times like you know whatever
dozens of times we still sell out of products we
just had that issue like this week we've switched
fulfillment centers four times and you don't know
what it's like to ship a warehouse of stuff across
like the country we are we one time though we had
a box manufacturer that had a huge difference we
had to get a new box thing and I was like yeah
just ship it in and the guy was like I don't think
you really understand what this but how many boxes
you wrote I go it's boxes just ship the boxes
because this is three semi trucks of boxes and
I was like got it got it I will put a tiny bit
more thought into this uh we'll get back to you
later so you know the but but today you know we
have we're we've gotten to a place where really
making the returning customer the community that
we've built the the population that already knows
us and likes us fall in love with us is really
the critical is so critical is that you know that
getting that lifetime value of the customer up you
know keeping those evangelists involved keeping
them excited keeping them happy and always always
staying kind of new and fresh to them without
actually straying from the authentic story that
brought them to us right like how do you stretch
your story to somebody new who maybe doesn't care
about one piece while staying true and honest to
the population that already does care about you
so much and so that's been a big kind of component
piece that we from from kind of a theoretical
stance that we sit back and think about every
day and then you know we are still hawkish on
our overhead we are hawkish on our inventory
we do try and make sure that all those all those
issues and the other kind of huge problem for any
clothing brand or fashion or Peril brand holiday
is huge right like that is the that is the those
two months represent a huge piece of our year but
you need to order all that stuff in June July and
August so now you need to get the capital in place
to actually get all those orders then get it into
the warehouse and then predict what the holiday is
gonna bring which is just an exercise in futility
for a bunch of years until we finally got some
stability in our growth but I'll tell you the
you know staying in the community is really the
piece that we probably care about and think about
most every day yeah I used to say that uh starting
a business was one of lynching things I've ever
done of going through cancer and and now I say
that scaling a business is the most challenging
thing I've ever done and starting the business was
actually a bunch of piece of cake so it was a good
time it was a blast I think that there's just you
know we've we've passed a million we've passed our
second we've got eyes on our five and our ten and
you know there's there's opportunity to grow but
like growing turns into different things right
and and like Bradford said earlier if you're not
passionate about what you're doing and you're
not really pushing yourself forward and you
really truly love this like you know the founder
fatigue is very real right I mean I've been doing
this for now nine years and you know every year
not to mention the last three that have just
been disastrous as far as like society and and
business and and work uh goes with it and you know
inflation and now you know the future recession
and the job market going up the job market going
down and you're just you know a lot of these
external issues become your internal issues
because you're actually dealing with them in real
time and you're trying to run and grow a beautiful
amazing business that you're so passionate about
but then you've got all these things happening in
the world that are also affecting how you look at
your day-to-day business and and so you're sort
of balancing on on all of these balls in the air
and you've got you know team we've got problems
with workers we have problems with employees
you have problems with you know society and
money and now all of these things become part of
your day-to-day decision making just so you can
continue to run your business and it's you start
to get you know more money is more problems when
it comes to business I don't think it actually
starts to solve problems because more just start
generating so you just have one problem now you
have 10 problems and you know all of those are
addressed on an everyday basis so it can become
quite intense anybody that's survived business
not even just in the apparel business anybody
that has survived pre-covered during it and now
um we all have a different Outlook um people
famously have talked about black swans and
you know how science had proven that there was
only white Swans in the world for all time until
somebody saw one in Australia and it was black
and then it disproved all prior scientific data
we are living in a Black Swan world right now
shipping no longer holds accountable fuel prices
are no longer accountable you're forecasting
for your employees is no longer accountable
you can't even get employees if you're I can't
find sewing machines I can't find my parts my
shipping's broken down my import fees are going
insane uh everything that you possibly thought
could go wrong is going wrong every day and you
have no control over any of it so how do you stay
calm in a world that you have no control over and
I mean like anybody that survived the last four
or five years you know coming into it during
covet and now will probably tell you the same
thing regardless of its apparel or anything and
it's your ability to move quickly to stay on your
toes and to lower your overall overhead as well as
being as closely vertically integrated as possible
and I would tell you that that is specifically
for the clothing industry you know uh Brian
you mentioned the forecasting for the
holiday seasons and everything like that
um I wish our forecasting was six months I have
to be working like during covet I think we were 18
months out because I was losing sea cans I'd order
a c can of material and show up in Athens three
months later they just turn off the GPS location
you know like how do how do you mentally even deal
with that and then you know Diana you were talking
about just the founders fatigue and you put in so
much energy to get this business rolling over a
million and you're like man this is it I did it
and then you're like wait I just have a whole new
table of problems you know it isn't ever that you
hit this that you hit this space or the ceiling
and then you're just allowed into a new room and
they're like hey all your problems are gone no
they just give you a whole new set of problems
that you have no understanding on how to deal with
because all of the solutions that you use to get
there no longer apply so I would say that all of
us have been able to stay on our toes and to lower
any overhead that is possible you know you're
reusing boxes you're trying to you're counting
the amount of pens that are in the office because
all of that adds up over time and your ability to
bounce between ideas to fail to retry to never
get dissuaded you know I started this because
I thought I was going to have no bosses and now
I have hundreds of thousands of bosses so that
also goes back to you know if you're starting an
apparel company don't do it for money go go get a
job if you're if you want to go get rich go get a
job you know because you're not going to succeed
as an entrepreneur or in the clothing industry or
the fashion industry if you're in this for money
because you have to be putting in 18 20 hours
a day and seeing no return you know because it
the product that you're working on might totally
flop so you know like you need to have passion
and persistence and be able to move very quickly
and pivot extremely quickly between your winners
your losers new ideas um you know what I
would say all of us that are still here um
have been doing that because you know we're still
here I know that there's a lot of people that
are going to watch this that are interested in
starting an apparel brand they probably wouldn't
be watching this video if not so I know one of the
big themes that we've been hitting on is you know
how you take your Creative Vision and then you get
hit with all these sort of operational challenges
um but I want to speak a little bit
to the upside a little bit because
um you know a lot of the things that Paul
mentioned are things that Brian and I you know
we yeah just it's it's a lot of head nodding I'm
getting a lot of exercises so but you know from
Brian and I's perspective one of the things that
we try to keep in mind is you know when we were
you know seven years old told that we were going
to lose our eyesight we didn't know how long how
fast the only person that I knew with this
condition is the guy on this call with me my
brother and I was like oh no way how'd you guys
meet we grew up all these little things that we
felt very isolated by you know learning to read
Braille I'm getting pulled out of school to do
that having to get up in front of a classroom
walking around with books that were three times
the size of the other kids having to explain to
strangers why we didn't recognize them and one
thing that we never understood about this project
when we jumped into it to have fun with each other
and do something nice for the foundation fighting
blindness are your customers become your community
and they become your community around sort of
these brand values that you've created you know
Brian and I we get to hear messages we got a note
from a guy who said hey I'm 19 years old my name
is Joe I'm in college I was just diagnosed
with retinitis Pigmentosa which is a disease
that closes in over time leading to complete
blindness he says I've been sleeping a lot
and then the next sentence he wrote is he said
I've been sleeping a lot because I'd rather be
asleep where I dream in 20 20 Vision than awake
losing my eyesight and you know thankfully broke
our hearts thankfully he went on to say a bunch
of positive things about connecting with the
community but the fact that Brian and I get to be
a megaphone for these patients this community the
fact that we get to have an influence on the
kids that were just like us growing up on the
moms and dads who were terrified like Armands
and dads and say something to them and through
you know and and be able to do a podcast like
this so that that kid with star guards gets to
see entrepreneurs doing what they're doing it is
the greatest reward you could ever imagine it's so
much better than me sleeping under my desk with my
private Equity job where nobody gave about what I
was doing so I do want to put that out there
for the folks that are motivated about this
because it can be a very rewarding experience and
I would love to hear Dana comment as well on that
like if I if I was doing this for money
I would have stuck with my career and I'd
be a top fashion executive right now with more
money than I would know what to even do with you
know and and I think that that's like a reality
right and and when you jump into this like your
community is your customer and in some ways in a
lot of ways we've created this community as well
um based upon when we launched in the internet
and what social media looked like and you know
we've changed conversations we've been at the
Forefront of empowering women to feel strong
and lovely about their bodies with or without
their breasts and nobody was doing that for
anybody before we launched our lingerie line and
I realized the conversations that we had to have
was a part of also identifying the use case of why
I was creating different bras and when I realized
the world didn't know what breast cancer was
because all we saw was pink ribbons and you know
pink tutus that we were actually having the right
conversations around breast cancer and how people
were amputating body parts to save their lives
right like this is a very very serious serious
cancer and do we have fun with it do we shine a
light on it absolutely but like you know when I
sit there with my team and I drive in like details
like Perfection all of these things because that
end customer is dealing with the worst day in
their entire life and we want to be a Beacon
of Hope for that and so I will grind and grind
and grind because we hear those stories just
like that every single day about how a life has
changed how a relationship has re-blossomed how
people can become confident again because like
that's why we're doing it right is that passion
and that experience behind it all to help make the
world a better place you know and I mean you know
Paul you said it like if it's about money don't
do it because that's not that's not where you're
going to find success and be you know and and find
happiness either because it's not going to come as
quick as you think it will there is no overnight
success that doesn't actually exist no but I go to
sleep every night hoping it'll happen you know I'm
just I'm like pretty confident tomorrow it's gonna
be there yeah well and and that's the thing like
every year I'm like man next year is the year next
year is the year you know and we've we all have
that persistence you have that drive and we all
get a kick out of it you know it's through
the stories through your connections with your
customers it's it's the Tuesday afternoon when
you're spending time with your family with your
kids walking your dog being like this is amazing
I have created something that allows me to live
my life as I want to as well as having a positive
impact but you need you need to want it more than
anything else you've wanted in life and if you do
you will find success in it you know but you need
it you need to be pushing harder than anybody else
you've ever you've ever thought because it is that
push to get you over that hump to start meeting
those customers because you know it'll start out
with one person buying one bra they're going
to tell one other person and then that other
person is going to tell one other person you know
and it sort of seems to be the same story between
all three of us I sold one recycled wool shirt to
one person and I said tell your friends wear this
circular economy can work then they came back
a year or two later with their friends so you
need the persistence to drive you long enough
to allow the community that you're creating to
help support you you know and I'd say that goes
back to you know some of your points Ryan where
it's like you know maintain that low overhead
keep everything tight and you know Diana you
just keep you keep driving it you know and you
believe in yourself you guys have talked about
team a lot I'm curious what was the most
important hire for you was it the first
hire was it a more recent hire and in terms
of the actual role like what is this person
doing that alleviated a lot of stress for you
what was your single most important hire well
we have the greatest team like TBB has just a
total Rockstar team I mean we are a tiny you
know we're not tiny we're actually pretty big but
uh we just the the most important hire I don't we
don't know yeah that's really hard to quantify
because what Brad and I did which we feel really
that hap that one thing that one thing that having
a disability like you know writing a lot of these
blindness we're bad at a lot of stuff like we're
just legitimately not good at many things and it
forces us to hire folks that are good at those
things and not have an ego attached to just giving
them up right like I'm not you know we're not
great at copywriting or detail you know like or
or rating through spreadsheets they're actually or
actually forecasting some of that stuff so we had
to bring in you know Angela who runs all of our
operations who just is a total rock star Brad is
just extremely forgetful I love him but he's you
know he's good at a million things that's not at
best but you know Rachel sits there and and keeps
our everybody in line on time and is willing to to
grab and do everything in Katy for product came
in and professionalized the whole thing in rhyme
with video editing all that like these photos are
just not having ego attached to jobs is so utterly
critical and to let somebody else go be great if
you're going to hire them assume that they're good
like you didn't hire them to be average and let
them just go be great at what you hired them to do
and don't get in their way because if you do that
why even have the job why even have the role why
even have a brad if you're not going to let them
go run and be free and for all I can play and do
the best thing that he can every single day I mean
that's that's the core thing is don't just hire
people and let them work when you're small hire
the person not necessarily the job description
because people wear a lot of hats and you need
reliable people who can execute and theoretically
there should be a lot of low-hanging fruit when
you're you know getting started so having those
people that can chase those opportunities
down with you is very important I'll add
to that because uh I and I don't know if you
all have heard this before because as brothers
I'm sure you guys you know you came as a team
which was great um which is is great but I I am
a solo founder and you know for very very long
I you know as I looked for investment dollars
as I was scaling it was a big Nick against my
company structure was that I was a solo founder
um I think that also comes a little bit with
being a woman so I I add that caveat because
there are very few men that ever get questioned
if they have a co-founder or not but but women do
um and it's very common so I I think that you know
when you're thinking about hiring especially if
you're starting this out on your own I I would
say out of both sides of my mouth try to find a
partner right because it does help carry the load
and as you scale um you end up carrying every load
on your shoulder so then when it is time to start
hiring people it's very hard to understand what
you can offload and what you need to keep so I
I say to kind of answer your question a little
bit who's your best hire it's really yourself
yeah because I think you have to understand as
a Founder as somebody growing a business what is
your optimal skill set that cannot be replaced by
anybody else once you identify that if you're the
sales person if you're the Visionary if you're the
executor know what you are best at and fill in
everything else around yourself because if you
start taking away what you're best at to do things
that you aren't so good at rather than hiring
somebody you're just gonna slow down and install
because it's really really difficult so you know
your brothers you guys have figured it out because
you're like hey we are really bad at these things
but some of us go in saying we can do anything and
then all of a sudden you are doing everything and
getting people to do the other things that can
be a challenge because you're just so ingrained
in so many parts of your business yeah I would say
hire for trust hire for the person again you know
I think Brad you're saying it like don't
don't hire specifically for the job
um when you're scaling and when you're growing
like this it is so crazy you need to be acting
so quick so fast so on your toes and also so open
you know in this discussion we've talked a little
bit about ego don't hire anybody with an ego it's
just going to be an absolute disaster because they
you know they get held on to well I always used to
do the wholesale so I have to do the wholesale and
it's like well no you're not good at the wholesale
you should go do the operations well I always used
to do the operation so I'm doing the operations
it's like no you know like what's best for the
company what's best for the team what's cohesive
you know and that's another big thing is as you're
growing you're going to be adding to the team
make sure that you're creating a team that is
so important the individual hire is important but
the team is the most important because you're not
going to get to one million plus 5 million
plus 10 million plus by hiring individual
islands of ego and attitude and operations or
marketing or branding you need a cohesive brand
and you need a cohesive team so I would say when
you are hiring people make sure that everybody
can work well together and you know I would tell
you I failed more than I've succeeded I have just
had the persistence to keep trying so when you
are working with new people make sure they're
okay with failing you know entrepreneurship
is all about failing trying something having
like I have the best idea and then watching it
fail and then having somebody else that you're
like that is such a bad idea succeed and then
being willing to be like wow that's actually
a wonderful idea we should move on with that
so I think um it's it's the characters it's
the characteristics of the person almost
it's more important than the specific job
um that we have hired four has been the most
beneficial for us amazing now as we wrap up
it's crazy how time flies when you're having fun
I'd love just two minutes from each of you final
message if you go back and think about you in year
one or you in year zero getting ready for year One
what would your final bit of advice be just start
you're I'm just this isn't you know just start the
business I I there's no there's conceptualizing
and planning and and all that are fine and dandy
but just if you want to be apparel you want to
start an apparel brand go call a small batch cut
and so Google it find one make a hundred shirts
build a bad website the first website we had was
a dumpster fire that like literally looked like
you were gonna get viruses on it it was terrible
and we just started selling our 100 shirts and
then and you got to get on the field to actually
succeed and could you not anything in your head
doesn't exist so just get out there it is so fun
you sell his shirt you feel awesome you sell 10
shirts you feel amazing like you sit there and
these things start happening you do that first Fox
Five chasing news interview and you think you're
gonna be famous like the whole world lights up in
front of you so don't sit there and plan and plan
and plan and plan start and you will attract
the world to you as you need it it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be challenging but there is a
ton of success there we started this business
with a plan to donate a million dollars that was
our big Grand goal today we've donated a million
and a half dollars to retinal research I mean that
is a lot of researchers out there that are gonna
come up with new cures for blindness that is a lot
of community members that we can make an impact on
that's a lot of kids that are going to grow up
with star guards that are gonna show one percent
more empowered because of it if you want to be
the fashion Mogul you will 100 can but you can't
do it in your head you gotta just go make shirts
you've got to make the website you've got to film
yourself you've got to put out of that and just be
viciously passionate and you're gonna you're gonna
cross it and if you don't damn 100 shirts gone
you gotta you got a great story go do the next
one go do the next one with dresses and skirts and
pants and whatever else and then you'll be sitting
on here and I'll be listening to you because
you'll be bigger than we ever could be so just
goddamn start your business and then and
then crush it and then laugh at me like
that's the only one in the world Brian
I'm coming to your TED Talk come on baby
I mimic all of that but uh to add to that
uh ask for advice but don't always listen
and I will say that because I I constantly
was asking for advice and input and I was
getting a lot of mentorship uh mostly from male
professionals because there was very few female
professionals I could I could uh get networked
with uh 10 years ago and a lot of that has changed
but you know listen to their advice and and let
it inform you but don't let it shape you um if I
listen to anybody's advice when I told them I was
going to make you know a new breast cancer bra
if I listen to any of that shred of that early
advice I would not be here today changing people's
lives because everybody told me it wasn't
a business I would never make money there
wasn't enough customers it was too Niche if it
was a problem somebody else would have already
solved that I can go on and on and on about how
my idea was discredited over and over and over
again when I first started but what it did tell
me was that advice meant that the world didn't
understand what I was doing and that very much
informed my business and the way I've treated
my business ever since I've created it so listen
to it it's not negative right it's coming from
a point of view and a perspective of people that
have been in the industry for a very long time and
understand these things but when I kept hearing it
over and over again I knew there was a big Missing
Link which allowed me to lean into the disruptive
forces I was going to provide eventually I didn't
know what they were I didn't even realize I was
disrupting an entire industry but that's what
I ended up doing because I didn't listen to
them right so but it helped me understand how
I needed to talk so people did understand what
I was doing so ask for the advice but you know
they know you know what they say about opinions
everybody's got one just like other things on
our body so you know take it as a grain of salt
but it is still important to you know seek out
that advice and hear it nonetheless yeah I mean
everything that everybody's saying is so true
um believe in your creativity creativity will
solve The World's problems whatever they may
be a lot faster than rules and regulations and
bureaucracy so whatever you want to do do it
full tilts have the persistence never give up but
really focus on your creativity um the people and
the youth and the Next Generation coming up you
will be the ones that solve our problems we can't
solve them because we're so ingrained with telling
people exactly what has worked for us now what has
worked for us has brought us to this situation
now to move forward in any of our problems we
need creativity and we need a different Outlook
now as everybody watches this YouTube Take Your
unique Outlook take your unique ideas and take all
these other clothing brands and ideas and see what
they're doing and then take your own personal spin
on them and you're going to be told no because
nobody else is doing what you want to do so
listen to them hear them but don't focus on them
don't get don't get held down with everybody
being like we don't need that we don't need
this we don't need that you're crazy don't do that
because if they have the same vision of you they'd
be doing it you know so I would say you just
need a lot of persistence and a lot of creativity
and creativity comes at us in all different ways
some of us it's through the t-shirts some of it's
through the design some of it's through the actual
products some of it is your supply chain all of
those little pieces and you know don't discredit
yourself and don't discredit your own ideas give
them a go get out there and try it and uh you know
just keep trying yeah I agree with everything that
was said you know the I guess the last thing I'll
say is you know I think it's important to reflect
on the moment in time that we're living in I mean
we're really living through a a technological
Revolution you know 15 years ago if Brian and
I wanted to start this project we would have
had to like do a mass inventory by do like a
Super Bowl ad Nuance the message or you know
un Nuance the message so that we could you know
get relationships with giant retailers you know
think about the fact that you can almost create
a website pretty much for free these days you
can go on a YouTube channel like Evans and learn
you know some great entrepreneurial principles
you can take MBA classes for free online from
some of the leading universities in the country
um and you can test advertising you know with a
few bucks I mean we are this is a ripe opportunity
maybe you know another 10 years or 50 years from
now these types of opportunities won't exist so
I think it's very exciting for anybody out there
who's interested in looking at this it's not easy
but it's a very rare moment in history where
you can do this so um so very exciting and it
gets us fired up to hear about other folks doing
it it's been a real pleasure amazing well thank
you guys for your time for your generosity for
the advice it's it's awesome connecting with
Purpose Driven entrepreneurs try to make a
difference in the world from all walks of
life and I learned a lot in today's session too
guys if you like these people go check out their
websites we'll link it up in the description
below appreciate everybody and we'll see you
soon thanks Evan just start to see the top 10
I did on Fashion Icon Carl Lagerfeld check the
video right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see you
there if there's a secret of your our success
there's no secrets the only secret is work huh
we'll get you act together there are not so
many secrets and also perhaps a decent life